[MUSIC PLAYING]
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: So you
know any migration is always
complicated because migrations
aren't a thing that we
do as a business, right?
When you start a
technology business,
your goal isn't
to do a migration.
So it's a rare occurrence
in anyone's lives,
and it always brings with
it anxiety and a lack
of understanding of what
we need to do to really be
able to push this ball forward.
So we're not here to tell
you about what technologies
to pick, how to avoid that weird
GKE load balancer issue that
happens every now and then.
But rather, if you're
an engineer here,
if you're a manager here,
if you're a leader here,
each one of you today owns a
piece of your business, right?
You're no longer
just doing work.
You actually own a
piece of your business.
So our goal here
is to teach you,
as an owner of that piece of
the business, what can you
do to plan and execute
effectively on the piece
that you own.
And also how you are
able to collaborate
better so that, as
an organization,
you can manage something that
can be pretty large and complex
and a fair amount of unknowns.
So the way we're
going to do it is
give a little bit of information
about who the key players were
here, what Google brought to
the table, and who Unity is.
And we're going to talk
about the why, the vision,
what was our partnership, and
what was the goals of what
we were trying to achieve here.
And then, finally,
we're going to give you
details about the approach--
what we did, how we
did it, what worked
for us, what didn't work
for us, and hopefully,
takeaways that you can
walk away with that
will help you make your
next migration a lot easier.
SOM ROY: So as we
start, I just wanted
to quickly talk about
Google Professional Services
Organization.
There might be some other
folks in the room who
are working with your TAMs or
your PSO team on the ground.
If not, you know,
PSO's mission is
to help customers get the
most out of Google Cloud.
And basically, we go to market
in three separate pillars.
We have our consultings
on migration services.
We have our Technical
Account Managers, the TAMs,
which some of you are
working with already.
And then we have our
training and certification.
So these three together forms
our Google Cloud Professional
Services, and our
aim is to work almost
as an extension of your team and
get all the feedback back over
to our product and engineering.
So as we start, we'll talk
about the Unity and Google
Partnership first.
Venk, do you want to?
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah.
So who is Unity?
I'm hoping a fair
amount of you know us,
but I'll cover it anyway.
We are the world's most popular
3D content creation system.
And we started with games.
We expanded into the 3D
content creation space.
But really, what we are is
a complete game creation
platform.
Our pillars of create,
operate, and monetize
allow game developers
to build a business.
Because today, game
development is not just
about building games.
We have to build a viable
business around it.
And game developers, what
they do best, is build games.
So Unity's goal is to
take away the rest of it
and make it really easy for
them to build a viable business
around their games.
Now, we've been in
Play for a while.
And we are wildly
popular in many spaces.
We've had over 29
billion installs
with some kind of
Unity experience
in it within just
the last 12 months.
60% of all AR and VR content
today is powered by Unity.
Now we're 50% of all new mobile
games are today built on Unity.
And then the Unity
Google Cloud Partnership?
SOM ROY: Yes.
So as you can see
here, I'm already
sporting it on my jacket.
So Unity and Google Cloud
also partner together
on this thing called
the Connected Games.
The whole point
of Connected Games
is to connect players to each
other and players to developers
as well and basically provide
a more enriching experience
to game players.
So Google Cloud and
Unity specifically
are partnering on that.
Again, as you can
see, we have a lot
of initiatives with Unity
going on across the company.
But this is something we
are very, very specific
on Google Cloud and Unity.
And if you need
more information,
you can read up on Connected
Games on the Unity blog.
All right, so as we
start, Venk, do you
want to give an overview of
how your engineering side?
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah.
So one of the unique
challenges we had
was that our team
is extremely global.
Unity today is in over 30
offices, in over 22 countries
worldwide.
We have close to 10 key
locations across the globe.
So a company that is built
like this cannot operate
in a extremely
top-down structure.
So we focus very heavily on
collaboration and empowerment.
And I'm bringing this up
because, as you were starting
out on your migration,
it's very important for you
to know how your
organization is structured.
This actually plays
a very important part
in how you're going to
plan and how you're going
to execute on the migration.
So for us, this was
a unique challenge
that I wanted to highlight.
SOM ROY: While it's really
cool on Unity's side
to be globally distributed,
it becomes really
a big challenge when
you're a services arm
and you're trying to
achieve the migration.
So we started thinking about,
from the Google PSO side,
how do we map a team to address
Unity's global and distributed
nature of business.
So we started with teams in San
Francisco, Seattle, and Austin
in the Americas.
We quickly realized
that we have to scale up
our team in the EMEAs, across
Stockholm and Helsinki,
where one of their key
business units are.
We also had a team
out there in London.
And as you can see,
in the previous slide,
Unity does have an office
in Shanghai, China.
So Google doesn't have
a PSO team in China,
so to map to that in
the same time zone
we had to have a team
in Singapore, which
was in the same time zone.
Now, this is really important
because local time zone
interaction during a tight
schedule and a timeline
is really important.
And having that local support
in where the migration is
happening, this is really--
that's why we went with this
global nature of the team.
Also, sometimes,
when issues come up,
the teams cannot wait for
eight hours for US to wake up
and actually get their
questions answered.
So removing the local
blockers was-- like,
removing blockers
in local time--
is a really, really
important thing.
The third thing is the
camps across the globe
were kind of always keeping a
tab on how the migration was
going on.
So, again, we had TAMs in
all the regions that we saw.
All right, so when we try to
summarize the whole migration
journey in one slide, it's
really, really difficult.
Because there are, as Venk
said, so many business units
across so many cities.
Again, there was a
very tight timeline.
The migration has to be
completed within 2018.
So we tried to represent
the whole journey
in at least one slide.
The important thing that I
want to draw your attention
is, if you see the
red box there which
says the pre-migration,
and then the green box,
which is the migration.
This is really important.
As Venk could kind of agree to,
we spent a lot of time building
out the foundation in
the first three months.
Now, there were concerns.
Are we moving fast enough?
Are applications
coming on to cloud?
And we basically, as a
joined team together,
we had to push back and say that
it's really, really important
to set up your foundation first.
You need to set up your
network, your IM, your security
controls.
And what we saw is, because we
spent three dedicated months
in the first phase of
the migration, the phase
0 and the phase 1,
the next six months
were highly, highly accelerated.
So if you are embarking
on a migration
or you are just about to kind
of start a migration phase 1,
please do build your
foundations properly.
Because, I think,
if you do that,
I think it's just
easier to bring
the applications
and the workloads
later in the remaining
half of the year.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah.
This plan at the beginning
looks counterintuitive, right.
In fact, when we
went and pitched
this, what it essentially looks
like, that we're basically
training for half the
time on a eighth month
migration for what is
a extremely high scale
set of services.
But there was a plan behind it.
Because when the teams
were ready to go,
they were ready to
really run with it.
We had made sure to account
for all of the major blockers.
We're going to cover this
in more detail about what
we did within that pre-migration
period that really set us up.
But this point is so
important that we're
going to highlight
it a few times
through this presentation.
There is a lot of value in
taking the time to prepare.
SOM ROY: And one
more thing, what
kind of caught us off guard
a little bit last year
was GDPR was the hot thing.
A lot of your--
if you're a
customer, you've been
hit with the GDPR requirements.
So again, it goes back
to the foundation.
If you set the
foundation right, I
think getting compliant
on many of these standards
are pretty much easy later on.
So we also did spend a bunch
of time on the GDPR part
because that was literally
the time when everybody
had to be GDPR compliant.
So given such-- and I see
this across all the customers
more so for a very, very tech
savvy digital native customer
like Unity-- is they are pushing
our products and our platform
to the boundary.
Like Venk said, 29
billion downloads--
there are millions of
transaction, even billions,
in a minute, per second.
So it's a very intense
application stack
that they have.
So as part of that, there are
many, many things that came up.
The TAM team and the PSO team
overall worked very closely
with our engineering
and product teams
to actually unlock
a bunch of features.
GKE, shared VPC was kind of
[INAUDIBLE] at that time.
Cloud Composer, GKE
private cluster-- these
were absolutely a major
blocker to the migration.
And kudos to our
product teams who
were able to get those
products [INAUDIBLE]
during the migrations
and we were
able to move all
the workloads over.
But there is always newer
things coming down the pipe,
as you saw.
I think I just saw
an announcement
around Traffic Director.
So it was really
important, and I think all
thanks to the Unity team.
We said that when we have
a ten feature request,
it's really important to
prioritize those feature
requests.
Like, what are the things
that will block the migration?
What are the things which
are kind of nice to have,
that in the next six
months, if they go
[INAUDIBLE], that will be fine?
And what are the
things that you would
need one year down the line?
And I think that collaboration
with the Unity team
worked really well.
They said the private GKE
cluster and the shared VPC
were really, really
critical items that
needed to be in the migration.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: What this
slide also highlights, really,
is the fact that
a lot of you are
going to think of your migration
as your burden to carry.
But it's not.
It's a partnership.
There is a team of
people out there
that don't just
sell this product,
but they're proud
of this product.
They want to learn
more about it.
They want to know what you
need and what you're missing.
They want to come to the table.
And what it does for
you is it actually
makes it a lot easier
for you to understand
the insides of the product too.
But for us, we really focused
on understanding not just
how the product
worked but also what
didn't work for the product.
Because it wasn't
important for us to pick it
if it worked perfectly but
rather, just like any business
today, what's down
the roadmap, what
can we use today,
how do we set it
up so that we can work
around any potential issues.
And that doesn't
happen in a silo.
So any partnership
for any migration
requires that you
actually invest the time,
as part of your
pre-migration strategy,
to really learn with the
team about what they have
and how it works.
SOM ROY: So if you look across
the different Unity business
units across the stack,
they're using a lot of products
right now.
Even after the
migration was complete,
newer work teams are
getting kicked in.
I think 2018-- correct
me, Venk, if I'm
wrong-- was a focus was really,
really on lift and shift,
move the workloads over to GCP.
2019 is more around
enhancing the data,
looking at email use cases.
So I would say last year
was very, very focused
when we did the migration
around compute, storage,
networking, all of the core
foundations of the stack.
And 2019, again, as I
said, the story only
starts after the migration
when the workloads actually
come over.
So this year, we are
actually working with Unity
to enhance that and spend our
time in the data and email
space.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN:
And once again, this
was not a generic
decision that we took
by looking at the technologies.
We look deeply within
our architecture
and evaluated per situation
what makes sense to take over.
It became very
quickly clear to us
that compute was a central
piece of our technology.
So it wasn't enough that
we just lift and shift it.
We had to look at
Google-managed technologies
and figure out what we could use
there in order for us to scale.
On the other hand,
Unity has always
been very, very
passionate about data
and about machine learning.
But those were things that were
very customized within Unity
to date.
So in that case, it didn't
actually make sense for us
to try to bring it over
within the Google setup
because a
re-architecture would be
too much for us to handle at
the same time as a migration.
So we looked at each
piece individually
to make a decision about
how we had to move it over.
SOM ROY: So why was
this important, Venk?
Can you give you an example?
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: So I
don't know if any of you
know this game "Apex
Legends," but once we finish
the migration over, we had
our multiplayer platform now
able to support
workloads through GCP.
And when "Apex" launched,
it was a huge launch.
For those of you
that remember it,
they had over one
million players
within the first couple of days.
Today, they have over
50 million players
in and out of the game,
2.3 million simultaneously.
And this is around the world.
So at peak times, we're actually
using 230,000 compute cores.
I mean, pretty sure we've
maxed out the Google quota
multiple times
through this process.
But it was possible to really
quickly launch this and scale
it because the backing and the
foundation of GCP and the way
that we architected
it was solid.
SOM ROY: Yeah.
This is really important.
Like Google Cloud with scale
up, and it will scale up
to handle such launches.
But again, because
we kind of set up
the networking and
IM, and the security,
collaboration with the Unity
team, that just adding cores
was relatively the easier
part of the problem
once we set up the foundation.
Then again, we keep
harping on that point
because, I think
both for me and Venk,
that is really
close to our heart
that we spent that time
in the first quarter.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN:
So let's dig really
deep into how we actually
planned this migration.
So here's the background.
Now, we talked about
the partnership.
The partnership was
not just a PR spiel
that Som and I came up with
because our companies told us
to.
The partnership
is important here
to mention because
we actually had
to take this vision not
just to the executives
about the importance
of this partnership,
but you actually have to do
that for each one of your teams.
You cannot expect your teams to
believe and move independently
on something as key as a
migration unless you explain
to them the vision, the
goals, and the business value.
And if you're not doing
that with your teams,
then you're not empowering them
to be part of the business.
So when we set up
this partnership.
We took that to the teams.
And we empowered them by
explaining the problem.
And after that, we
got out of the way.
We empowered them
with the problem
and asked them to come up
with the right solution.
We told them all of
the business needs,
the deadlines, what happens
if we go over x versus y,
how is spend affected
through this year.
We laid it out for the teams.
And when I say teams, I don't
just mean the directors.
I mean every
engineer, every lead,
had access to this
information and was
encouraged to know about it.
When you do that,
now you have teams
that are truly bought
in because they're
aligned with that vision.
And then it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
The second thing we did was
we used this as an opportunity
for evaluation and refresh.
One of the things that you
hear a lot in the industry
is lift and shift or
transformation, right?
And it becomes this binary
thing that you're solving for.
You're either taking
all of your crap
that you have in your
house and moving it over,
or you're just scrapping
it entirely and just buying
everything new.
But that's not
really true, is it?
Every situation is unique.
You have to look
at every scenario
and evaluate using the
guidelines and the goals
that you've outlined as
part of the empowerment
to understand what makes sense.
So for example, in
our case, we had been
using our own Kubernetes stack.
But we took the time
to evaluate GKE,
and we realized
the value that it
was going to bring because what
we had was essentially many,
many sets of isolated
Kubernetes clusters.
But what GKE allowed
us to do was really
centralize that
system, and it actually
fundamentally changed how we
operate as an organization.
Today, instead of having every
team figure out their own GKE,
we've centralized
these things back
to teams that are
dedicated to it.
As in, they are experts in GKE.
They centralized the modules.
They roll out the clusters.
We use different models
to help other teams scale.
But when we made that
decision, it actually
helped us move faster.
We did the same thing
with logging too.
We had an in-house
stack that we had always
been a little
troubled by because it
wasn't super effective.
When we looked at Stackdriver,
we evaluated the advantages
we get in terms of gained
people back into the workforce
because they don't have
to worry about managing
an in-house stack versus what
it would cost us to run it.
These are real things.
These are practical things
that each team should not
be looking at.
It shouldn't just be happening
at the executive level.
On the flip side, we have
a highly customized data
pipeline.
And that was not something that
we wanted to take to chance.
We evaluated Pub/Sub
and our evaluation
was that we're going
to move it over,
or we're going to evaluate
how to move it over next year.
So that one, we actually
knew because we'd
done the math behind it that
it made more sense for us
to take as is.
Now, one of the things
that was to our advantage
was we were a
distributed architecture.
We've kind of been
very microservice mesh
from the beginning.
Everything that we do is
API and message based.
So essentially, we already had
a bunch of independent layers
that we could figure out
how to migrate them over.
Now, I call this out because
this worked to our advantage.
But there are technologies that
you're working on that maybe
a monolith, that maybe
multiple monoliths,
or some version of a monolith
and a distributed architecture.
These are important
because you have
to do your own
independent evaluation.
It's not just enough to look
outside and pick the standard
that everybody else is using.
And then, global teams, again,
we've talked about this before.
This was a particularly
unique problem for us,
which is we're trying to
do a migration in a very
short timeline with teams
that are across the world
and how do we coordinate that.
So what we did, and I'm going
to cover this in the next slide
in planning, what
we did essentially
was really kind of
focus on the results
rather than the process.
We focused on
empowering these teams
so that they could move on what
they needed to independently.
But we had to come up with ways
to be able to track the system.
And finally-- and this was
the toughest part-- business
continuity during the migration.
There was no stopping
for the business.
We continued to work on
new products and features
and rolled them out.
We had no downtime while we
migrated a high-scale system.
I mean, we have 2
to 3 billion users
in and out of this
system every month.
We processed 20,000,
30,000 events every second.
And all of this
is at low latency.
In some cases, the
latency requirements
were so strong that we had to
pick data centers on both sides
so that we could route
in under 10 milliseconds.
And we did all of that without
experiencing any downtime.
SOM ROY: And that,
I think, Venk,
is another key point
that always comes up.
Again, from the PSO side, we
always see the customer saying,
or our engineer is going
to build the next product,
or are they going to
focus on migration,
because they are both
equally time taking.
And while, on one side, you
have to make the business go
forward, come up with
the new features,
you also have to
finish this migration.
So I think just the
balance that the Unity
team, with the help
on the PSO side,
we were able to create
was really, really a--
that's one of the key things
why these things went well
and we were able to complete
this within a short time frame.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN:
And again, for us, it
was a practical
decision because we
looked at the logistics of it.
If we're building a
feature, what value
do we get with
differing sections
of the migration
versus what do we
get from speeding up the
migration in certain aspects?
We always went
back to the basics.
We always looked
at the goals when
we were trying to solve these
day-to-day tough problems.
So migration planning--
we already covered this,
but plan twice, execute once.
I cannot stress this enough.
Now, what did it actually
mean when we did planning?
We started with the
very, very basics.
We put the people into
Qwiklabs and Coursera.
We gave them access
to online training
that they used to pick
up at least the basics
of a new system
because most of us
were actually unfamiliar
with GCP to begin with.
Then, we went into the
next stage, which is, now
that we understand
the basics, we
started to work closely
with the Google TAMs
to actually understand certain
technologies very, very deeply.
We'd already identified
things like GKE.
But it wasn't just enough that
we looked at the documentation.
So we would sit
down with the TAMs
and walk them through our
use cases across the board
and explain how we were planning
to use it and what made sense.
Then, we went even
one more level deeper.
At this point, we had
each of the teams that
owned pieces of the architecture
sit down for days on end
with the Google TAMs.
And the TAMs would bring
in their own experts
based on specific technologies
that we wanted to use.
If we needed a Postgres
equivalent, so Cloud SQL,
they would bring
those experts over.
If we were evaluating Pub/Sub,
then we would make sure
we had a Pub/Sub expert there.
And we would spend
all day in a room,
walking through the stack,
breaking it down over and over,
digging into how
they're supposed
to talk to each other, how
the firewall rules work,
how does access flow--
everything from
where do we set up
the projects to which
services run on which cluster.
We tried to lay as
much out as possible.
The advantage of doing this in
a very collaborative fashion as
opposed to having people go out
and write documents and review
it over and over is that
it really sped up the time
to get to the ideal result.
So we actually focused a lot on
just bringing people together.
We actually had people
fly to different offices.
We had local TAMs, and this
was another big advantage
of local TAMs.
Then, this actually gave us time
for learning and exploration.
So as I mentioned, we covered
a lot of detailed content
with the TAMs.
Once we had gotten to the
point where we understood what
each team had to do, we
went to the next level,
which was we actually started
doing cross team dependencies.
So we would have teams
sit down together
where known dependencies
existed, once again,
in collaboration with Google,
to talk through the details,
like, OK, how do we
manage latency here?
How do we manage
the data workloads
that are going to flow
through at peak periods?
This forces you to
do a lot of research.
This forces you to gather the
right metrics, to understand
your system better.
It's not just enough for
you to have the basics.
Everybody knows, well, how many
requesters their service deals
with, but you don't necessarily
know what your error rate is,
what your peak loads look like,
what patterns your traffic
flows through, how does it
deal with specific types
of exceptions.
Because when you move from
one stack to the other,
you're actually going to see a
change in where the errors are
generated because different
clouds handle resiliency
differently.
So we really focused
on those aspects.
Now, while the teams
are off doing that,
we were focusing on phase 0.
What is phase 0?
Compliance, security, SRE,
network, and developer tools.
So while the engineering
teams were off figuring out
how they could migrate, we had
actually set off the phase 0
teams, which, really,
if you think about it,
this is your foundation.
This is what creates the right
GCP foundation for you to use.
We had these teams off
and running in parallel,
setting up the actual stage
and production infrastructure.
So the engineering teams
were off in sandboxes
having these detailed
conversations
and learning more
about the tech.
And in the meantime,
security was coming up
with how do you set up the
Google Groups to set up
the right access.
How do you do editor
versus read only?
How do you do billing access?
Where do you give super admin?
How does SRE get
access to systems
across different
organizational units
at your company versus what
you do for your own teams
within your own
organizational unit?
We also covered compliance.
GDPR was a big one that
we were dealing with.
There's a lot of
little nitty gritty
that you figure out as
you're digging into it.
For example, GCP,
by default, does
geoblocking of certain
countries that are embargo.
And these are pieces
that you're only
going to figure out when your
compliance team gets in there
and asks the right questions
because that's what they do.
At the same time, network
was heavy, heavy focus.
We pushed bandwidth like crazy.
So we definitely had the
network team in there,
not just looking at how they
were going to use the existing
setup, but how we can
improve it and actually build
a much stronger
foundation for what
we knew we were going to
scale in the next three
to four years.
Now, workstreams and
dependencies-- so this
is a tricky one to
talk through, but I'm
going to hand-wave
my way through it
and hopefully you
guys are going to see.
Because this was actually a
critical part of our success.
What we focused on in this
whole pre-migration area
was building out workstreams.
Think of your workstreams
as layers within your stack.
At the very basic, you're
probably going to have network.
Then on top of that,
you're probably
going to have your
foundational pieces of how
do you start up the clusters.
Then you're going to have
the actual services that
run between them.
But the services are
also layered, right?
You will have your
backend services
that are talking to the data
pipelines, that are actually
talking to a middleware, that
are talking to a pure frontend
service.
So there's all these
layers that you have.
Now, if you're able
to neatly draw them
out so that they create
these parallel paths, what
you've effectively done is, one,
you've identified workstreams.
Each of these workstreams
is a cohesive unit
that can move independently.
Your data pipeline is
different from your services,
is different from your frontend.
The other thing
that you're going
to end up doing when
you draw this out,
you're going to have lines that
crossover between workstreams.
Those are your dependencies.
So now you know exactly who
talks to whom because you've
leaned this out in charts.
Towards the end,
we had giant charts
that had a ton of different
workstreams in them.
And so we actually ended
up creating workstreams
within workstreams
in some cases.
But when you're doing a
migration as a company,
you have the bandwidth.
You have the manpower to be
able to go and break it down.
So what we did was
each workstream
that we started with
was a business unit.
And then that
business unit would
go in and break down their
workstream into further layers.
But these layers
were very important.
One, we always had visibility
into what the layers were
and where the dependencies lay.
Two, we never ran into
the issue of people
not understanding how the
architecture was flowing
because this was always a great
reference point for us to be
able to lay back to.
Finally, tracking
the milestones--
so after we have these
workstreams and dependencies
laid out, it actually let
us track two milestones.
Now, I'm going to say this
to you a little differently
because a lot of us, when
we're doing this migration,
we're going to focus
on the process,
and we're going to
focus on the deadlines.
That's natural.
That's what we do.
But when we have a
global set of teams
and our goal is to
empower them, there
was no way for us to
be able to pull it off
by saying, hey, this is the
date you got to hit it by,
these are all the processes
that you have to follow.
So we kind of flipped
it on its head.
We focused on
milestones, not status.
And we focused on
results, not process.
So what that means
is every team was
able to own a piece of the
workstream independently.
All we did was create
standard milestones
that we could track
across these workstreams.
This is something as
simple as your stage prod
being milestones or a security
review being a milestone.
Like, pick your
milestones, right?
But they become standard
across the teams.
The second thing
we did was, when
we would collaborate, when
we would review updates,
we never focused on the status.
We focused on the results.
We focused on the milestones.
So what have you
achieved so far and what
are you going after next?
How can we help you get there?
Where do the dependencies
exist, and how can we
help bring the
collaboration together?
What it did was it kind
of changed the framing
of this whole migration.
It became less of a process and
it became more of a shared goal
that we were all going after.
The other thing that was unique,
at least in our situation,
was our teams used
different supporting stacks.
So not everybody is on
the same ticketing system,
not everybody is using
the same developer tools.
So once again, in
that case, how are we
going to actually track to this?
How are we going to know when
an engineering team has finished
x milestone because how the
traditional process grows,
right?
You put everything into Jira.
You create this giant chart.
And then everybody's looking
at it every week going,
oh, we slipped by two days here.
But that was not
what we wanted to do.
Because, again, the focus
was not the deadline.
The focus was the shared
vision, this goal.
So we actually took that
work into, believe it or not,
we spent a week creating
this tracker that essentially
took all these
disparate pieces of data
and just kind of rolled it up
into a simple workstream-based
progress.
And we shared that every
week across the board,
the executives,
they all knew what
was going on because it was
a very simple way to view it.
In fact, I think-- and
I'll say that out loud--
I believe Google
liked our tracker
so much that it may
be showing up now
as a template for
other migrations.
So if you see one
that looks kind
of like a set of
workstreams, that was us.
And then, finally, the
cadence for the global teams--
now, as I said, it's very hard
to track these global teams,
so we focused on the
goals and the results.
We tried really hard to
stay away from the process.
So at the end of
the day, this is
kind of a very, very
high level of what
the workstreams look like.
These cohorts are
essentially big milestones
that each one of these
people owned delivering.
And if you notice, it
was possible for them
to be extremely parallel.
Big ones we even broke down
into further workstreams.
And we had dependencies
tracked between them.
But the reason why we could
move on all of this in parallel
was because we focused on
making these workstreams as
independent as possible.
SOM ROY: And I think
the cohort was also
really defining what goes in
cohort one and two and three.
That was really
also very important
because it kind of gave
us a staggered approach.
And when we went live,
it wasn't all or nothing.
We went live at the first
set, everything worked well,
we went live with
the second one.
So I think that was
really, really useful.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah.
And we're actually going to
talk about some of our learnings
now because we also
stumbled along the way.
There were things
that we learned.
And they're kind of
the nitty gritty.
They're the practicalities of
when you try to do a migration.
So we'll start with the don'ts
because we always want to know
the don'ts first.
OK.
First of all, don't migrate
all of your baggage.
But also, don't migrate
none of your baggage.
You've got to pick.
Think about it like moving
into a new apartment.
When you move into
a new apartment,
you don't just take
all those boxes
that have been sitting in your
garage for months or years.
But you also don't just
leave them in the house.
You want to go through
and clean up as you go.
So do that.
Be practical about it.
And more importantly, don't
try to put a ton of process
around it.
Your engineering teams
know these things.
They know where the
baggage practically
can be moved versus not.
Just let the engineering
teams be empowered
to do something like this.
Two, don't build a snowflake.
If you have a snowflake,
don't migrate the snowflake.
We all have stacks, especially
if the technology we're
working on is a few
years old, we all
have these snowflakes
sitting around.
But the world has changed.
So much is out there now.
Google aggressively
looks across and tries
to find these common patterns.
So there are known
best cloud practices.
There are known application
patterns to follow.
Use them.
This is actually a
great time for you
to be able to reinforce them.
You know that there is
a VM out there somewhere
that is open to the internet
and nobody knows about.
You know there is
that one guy whose
laptop has access to the
production infrastructure.
Take the time to clean it up.
Take the time to put
better practices in place.
Don't migrate the monolith.
Now, this is a harder problem
than just putting it up
as a point on a slide.
So when you're
looking at a monolith,
do your best to apply
the strangler pattern.
Pull out what you can that's
safe, what's feasible,
and try to move that over.
It's actually going to
have a twofold result.
One, it's going to make your
monolith smaller and easier
to migrate.
But two, it's also going to
provide a proof of concept
for how to be able to
scale to bigger migrations
because you're going to pull
out really, really small pieces.
You can start with
simple things,
like your config service,
or your identity, or just
a connector to the database.
Separate out your
database through an API
and just move that over.
Now, don't retain single
points of failure.
This one was especially
important for us.
For example, I told you we used
network bandwidth like crazy.
So when we were
moving over to Google,
we really buttoned that up.
We created multiple points
of failures and redundancies
in there that has actually
allowed us, in recent times,
to deal with network outages
that we've seen that were
on the third party side.
But we've been able
to deal with that
because we actually took the
time to evaluate our bandwidth,
understand it, and then put
the right redundancy in place.
We did the same
thing for Kubernetes.
Multi-zone's always
a great idea.
Multi-region is even better.
But multi-zones are
always a great idea,
so we took the time
to do that too.
And finally, don't
re-architect everything.
Especially not your plumbing.
Don't try to move over to that
brand new monitoring system
while you're trying
to do a migration.
Move parts over that need
to be migrated and deal
with everything as a
separate initiative.
Now in some cases, they may be
tied together, in which case,
use your workstreams
and dependencies to be
able to separate them out.
If you treat your
developer tools
as a later workstreams
have a dependency on,
you're actually going to
create a phased approach of how
we're doing things.
SOM ROY: So, like
Venk talked about,
the very specific on
the technology side,
I'm going to talk about
the people and process side
as well because, until all these
three together come together,
you won't have a
successful migration.
So the first key don't on
the people process side
is please don't
migrate in a vacuum.
Think about the
downstream dependencies.
Think about what and
other teams downstream
are going to be impacted
by this migration.
And please involve all these
cross-functional stakeholders
when you do so.
If you don't do that, it's like,
even though your component is
successfully migrated, the
shared vision will not be met.
So no migration in a vacuum.
I think, don't
focus on deadlines.
I think Venk talked about it.
I'm not going to go
into the details.
I think it should
be shared goals.
It should be talking
about shared focus areas.
And everybody should feel
as part of the migration
and just saying, I have
to do it by October 30,
that's not going to
cut it because you
have to take everybody along.
Another thing which is
important is the lift and shift
versus transformation.
I think what the point
we are trying to make
is there is no one
correct answer.
Some of your components
will be lift and shift.
It makes sense to just
take what you're running
and just move it to GCP.
Versus some, you
should take the option
that you are doing a migration,
why don't you transform?
So each workstream should
be treated very differently.
Each component should be
different treated and evaluated
differently.
Across all the
workstreams, I think,
there is no mandate
that everything
needs to be either lift
and shift or transform.
I think the Unity's
migration was
a very good example of a mix
of both these approaches, where
it made sense.
We had a lift and shift
where it made sense.
We actually looked at a
transformation approach.
And then, just don't assume
that planning leads to success.
While the planning
is really important,
but following up
and executing on it
is really, really important.
And iterate on the plan.
In every migration
that we are seeing,
there are unknown blockers
that will crop up.
There will be churn in terms
of folks joining the team.
So you have to keep
iterating on the plan
because if you don't
iterate on the plan
and you just stick
to something that you
planned six months back, that's
not setting up for success.
So that is a really,
really key don't in terms
of from a process perspective.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: So now, what
to do from the technology side.
We've covered phase 0 in detail.
It is very important to
establish a solid GCP
foundation.
Because here's the thing
to remember-- the migration
is not the end of the journey.
It's the beginning of it.
You are tying yourself to a
technology for a long period
of time, hopefully.
Hopefully migration is not
what you do as a company.
And when you're doing that,
you want the foundation
to be extremely solid.
The more debt you
accumulate, the harder
it will be going forward.
Now, some kinds of
debt are isolated,
and you're going to
actually make calls on them.
But foundational
debt is different.
If your access controls are not
in place when five people are
in the system, it is going
to be a lot harder to do it
when 300 or 3,000 people are
going to be in the system.
If your network
firewalls aren't in place
to segregate the
environments when there
is no services in
there, it's not
going to happen when there's
thousands of services in there.
And what also changes
is the manpower
needed to do it at a later
time exponentially goes up too.
So it is very, very
important that you
establish this foundation.
Automate everything--
this is the key part.
So we actually took this
time to automate everything
that we found that was manual.
And we actually had it in
three different styles.
So everything was
infrastructure as code.
That was kind of the
principle that we aligned on
that we were going to do.
But also, when we were
looking at infrastructure
and we realized all
infrastructure was being
written as code, we
centralized a lot of the pieces
that we knew were in use across
multiple parts of the company
and we offered them
as infrastructure
as a service or
infrastructure as a framework.
And what infrastructure
as a framework--
I'm assuming all of
infrastructure as a service.
But what infrastructure
as a framework does
is it actually take some of
the burden of maintaining
the service and passes that on
to the user of that service.
And this works really
well for internal teams.
So as a good example, we had
many, many uses of Mongo.
And they were all isolated, some
of them were manually set up,
some of them were set up in
different kinds of automation,
and they all had different
configuration, different use
cases.
But we spent a time to
have a single team actually
pick up all of that, understand
from each of the users
what they were trying
to do, take it all back,
and rewrite it as a
centralized module.
Now, this module is a lot better
maintained because we actually
use automation to not
just deploy and run it
but we also use
automation to test it.
We have a team that's dedicated
to continue to improve it,
which means that you don't
fall behind on versions.
You don't fall behind
on new functionality.
You don't have bad bugs
sitting around in your system.
But also, it didn't make
sense for a team like this
to try to run every
database in the company.
You're just creating just an
unhealthy central dependency.
So we offered it
as a framework out.
We maintain the module, we
improve it, you go use it.
You own the cluster
that it runs on.
It also passes the ball a little
bit of making sure everybody
knows how to run infrastructure.
Most of us today understand
the concept of, you build it,
you run it, you own it.
In fact, at Unity, we have this
joke that says, you build it,
you run it, you pay for it.
Because our engineering
teams actually
know what it takes to
actually-- in terms of
spend for their services to run.
They use that to continuously
optimize their services.
And this is the
kind of empowerment
that you want to make sure
that you offer to your teams.
Minimize technical
debt-- now, we've
talked about technical
debt quite a bit.
Specifically, what
you want to look at
is just old debt that's
sitting around that's
going to severely hamper you.
In one of our cases, we had
a old, highly customized load
balancer that had
been written in house
that was sitting on a system.
And when we looked
at GKE, we knew
that we could re-architect
the system a little bit
and actually get rid of
this custom load balancer.
So we took the time to do it.
So minimize technical
debt where feasible,
especially fundamental
technical debt.
Don't take it with you.
Iterate and learn-- so the way
the workstreams were set up,
they were actually set up in
increasing levels of complexity
and collaboration.
So the first systems to go
out were extremely simple.
Most of them didn't even
have a back end database.
It was like a GCS.
But after a while, we started
to get into bigger services,
but those that were
completely independent.
Then you start introducing
a dependency layer.
So now you have
multiple systems trying
to go live at the same time.
So we did it slowly with the
goal of accelerating closely
towards the end
because you start
to gain momentum once confidence
builds from the deployment.
So our migration actually
looked like almost no work done
within the first three months
because we were focused
on the learnings
and the migration,
very, very minimal services
migrated over the next two
months because we were
getting our confidence
and understanding how
everything worked in stage.
And then, all of a sudden,
you start seeing you
high-scale services just
ramping up really quickly,
and all of that happened
within the last two,
maybe three months.
And finally, train,
plan, and prepare--
the reason why I'm
calling this out
is, separate the
artificial pressure
of learning from execution.
As an engineer, you know this.
When you are told to
practically learn on the go
or you're being asked to deliver
something that's brand new,
it creates this
artificial pressure of,
I need to do two things
at the same time.
So we just set it up in a way
that it took that pressure off,
the teams were able to focus
on learning and training first,
and then when they were ready to
go, they were able to execute.
SOM ROY: And finally, from
the people and process side,
what are the things
you should do?
I think this is very,
very like what we covered
in the don'ts is, don't
start in a vacuum.
So you should align on
overall vision and goals
for GCP migration.
Gaps in understanding,
it has to be
top-down as well as bottom-up.
Like, if the engineer
who is actually
working on the
migration doesn't align
to what the vision of the
company is to why big GCP
and where the
migration is going,
that leads to issues and
conflicts unnecessarily
and it will delay
your migration.
So then alignment
across top-down,
bottoms-up is really,
really important.
Establish a migration PMO.
This may sound like a really,
really old school term, PMO.
But project
management office does
help when you are
doing a large migration
with multiple workstreams with
so many different stakeholders
involved.
And absolutely identify
the right stakeholders,
both from the Google side as
well as from the Unity side.
That's really, really important.
Identify clear owners
because responsibility
and accountability, again,
a very old school term.
Who's responsible?
Who's accountable for the
success of that workstream?
That is really
important to identify.
The fourth one is, I
think, the one that is
really close my heart, which is
set realistic migration goals.
Aspiration versus reality,
like we keep talking about,
yes, let's use this migration
to do something dramatic.
Your entire stack
will change, something
will change drastically
versus, let's
be real in what can be achieved
in the six months, seven
months or one year of migration
that you're going to do.
So this alignment is
really, really important.
And you as a company
need to take a call
in what is the realistic goals.
Establish and track milestones--
I think Venk talked about-- and
I'm not going into the details
again because you don't
have so much time.
But have proper
tracking and make sure
that you're looking at it on
a weekly, bi-weekly, monthly
cadence.
Prioritize for risk
issues and features,
and this goes back
to the slide where
we talked about all the feature
requests that Unity had.
Like, please identify what
is P0 and P1s for you.
What is P2 and P3, and can it
wait for six months, one year?
Please do try to
actively identify.
It always works better both
for Google and the customer
if we have a prioritized list.
And on the last point,
Venk, do you want to--
I know this is--
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah.
This is the one I really
want to hammer home
because a lot of you
are going to treat
a migration as a project
that needs to be done.
But it's a unique event,
and it's an important event.
It actually sets the
stage for your company.
And it's not going to
happen without your people.
It's not going to happen
without your engineers.
So celebrate success.
We talk about people, process,
technology quite a bit.
But if you think of it in
terms of people, planning,
and empowerment, you're going
to get the right technology
as a byproduct of that.
If you focus on letting your
smart engineers be empowered
and then get out of the
way and focus instead
on how you can unblock them
and how you can help them get
to the right kind of
tracking and milestones,
they're going to get the
right results for you.
Deadlines are never the focus.
The goals and the vision are.
And that's it for us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]